The joe rogan experience for girls,
don't you think way worse.
Crazier men are dangerous and that's why we have a system called the patriarchy
took to women.
Like Michael Costa has a bit about,
I have a great system to protect women from the dangers of men called Patriarchy
and we threw it.
We Lord,
we threw it away.
Cause ecologist,
I think it's important to talk about patriarchy because I feel that young 20
year old women need their own Illuminati to talk about,
you know,
totally in their failures.
Got Us going on.
It's,
yeah,
it's like it's Illuminati for girls.
Fight
Patriarchy.
[inaudible] ask for the set definition.
There isn't one.
Is that a suspicious?
Same with racism.
Just one in the dictionary,
but that's not the accepted one.
Ask just any on my feminist.
What does it mean?
There's no,
well you can be whatever you want to be like.
It's,
it's,
it means you're my ex boyfriend named Gary Click of mean girls is that
patriarchy are in a position of power.
That's the patriarchy.
But men have been in the workplace for hundreds of years more than women is that
there's a real problem.
Well it should be caught up.
But what about when to hear this shit where somebody goes,
when people wonder where all the female Comedians,
I like no.
Who said that to people talking about it when it,
when Louie got shellacked by that fucked up article with people were saying that
shit about,
you know what,
how come there's an equal number of female comedians to males?
Well cause women are treated better in our society.
Yeah.
If there's a female comedians,
you know,
women are being abused way more than ever because you don't get in this job from
a happy,
his job isn't about support.
It's you get last cause you're fucked up.
So I hope there's not a lot of women in it that would mean they're being raped
more.
There's that.
But it is also,
it's just from a female perspective,
if a chick's funny,
it's harder because something happened to her.
They can't,
but they can't talk about certain things like,
no,
no man wants to see a woman on stage town politic stories or politic jokes.
If it's funny you say that,
but they did create a lot of the daily show.
Maybe you,
maybe you,
but most people in the audience,
the woman,
I won't rule out anything.
I'll take,
I won't say any premises Hacky,
just punch line.
So if your premise is airline fucking peanuts such fine,
tell me what your punchline is.
Maybe your punchline justifies it.
I don't,
I won't rule out any premise.
Premise is or hacky,
but people probably don't want to hear it,
but who you know,
it's like,
look,
if you can get people to listen to some shit that they basically don't want to
hear,
like,
oh great,
this is from,
I used to do the black rooms when I started out.
You're talking agreed with you.
I'm totally in agreement with you.
We're not talking.
What are they drinking?
Caveman coffee.
We're not talking.
He says,
I feel wired as wicked wire from that 270 milligrams.
How many did you might go?
Well,
I just started sipping wine,
but I'm like,
I feel like one that's empty.
Did you black out and suck though?
And Justin,
I just drank one.
What the fuck is this dude?
It's a debt talking about me.
I'm talking about most when a woman goes on stage and does stand up,
most people that are going to be in the audience,
there's men that are just not going to want to hear you talk about politics.
There's men that are not going to want to hear you talk about sex.
It's harder for a woman.
I think it's a hard,
it's a harder position.
Being a standup comic for a woman is just harder.
So I think if it's harder,
you're naturally going to see less people doing it and then there's naturally
less people inclined to do it,
but it's just like female MMA.
Like most women are not going to do it.
But guess what?
A lot of women do it.
If you're the type that does it,
you fucking do it,
but there's no fucking would.
What about the Patriarchy in MMA?
Why through equal number of women than men?
You don't say that right.
I noticed that.
Remember who the lead.
That's it.
I think it's cause it's an untenable argument.
What you can't say.
This should be an equal amount of women fighting as men because it's not.
That's what,
and punch in the face area.
That's one area where we agree it's one area we get to a goal yet,
well men,
they do this better.
This is,
they do it more.
They're doing it constantly and there's some elite female athletes in MMA,
don't get me wrong,
rivaled the elite athletes and men,
but they used to submit and they had the operation way more men fucking way
more.
I mean it's not even seen with basketball and WSP.
Right.
But this is what my point is the same as standup.
Yeah.
Cause standups another getting punched in the face sport to me like it's super
fucking difficult.
You take an emotional beat.
Some people don't want to do it.
It's not a judgment call.
It's not like you're better or you're worse.
I think I picked you because the people that left that I started,
I don't know if you think of when you started,
people who thought that were funny,
that left right,
and people that stage or he can't believe you're still here.
It's clearly a calling and not a,
yeah,
you got to be able to take a beating.
Some people just decide to,
they've had enough.
They like,
they don't want to get off this fucking ride.
You know,
there's a lot of guys that were like big time touring headliners and they got to
a point in there where the,
fuck this,
we usually go to Vegas or something.
Yeah,
yeah,
they do that.
Or they just fucking get some sort of a writing job.
Sometimes get writing jobs.
They started doing tree work like me.
They moved to the middle of nowhere.
Freeze outside,
just start cutting down trees.
You know,
I was,
I liked the writer's guild,
but listen,
man,
anybody who thinks there should be an equal number of men or women in any job
and that if there's no clear evidence that this is a neutral occupation,
that this is an occupation that doesn't favor any gender.
Like there's gotta be jobs where it's equally represented,
men and women.
Outside of that,
your job,
it's what you choose to do with your life.
When the boys grow up playing with fucking trucks and superheros and girls grow
up playing with dolls and they obviously are more inclined in this direction and
men are more inclined in that direction that we expect them to meet at any
interest.
And then we w that we would force it and force it,
ruins it for women.
It makes them think that they should do jobs,
that they might not enjoy it and then they get really depressed.
Right?
Yeah.
Or they think,
did they need to prove themselves by doing a man's job?
Exactly.
Instead of just doing what they actually enjoy doing.
Well,
I mean,
you know,
it's funny.
When I was a kid,
I remember my mom wanted to work and she got a job and then she was mad because
she wanted to stop working because it's so,
yeah.
Um,
but uh,
I mean it just depends on the level of need,
right?
Like what if there's like a war or a bad economy?
So I'm guessing what I'm going to go get people.
That's a different thing,
right?
It's different.
The poor,
like everybody was sort of bonded together because you know,
they have a make shit constantly seems to be a much more of a,
I,
you know,
I was telling my girlfriend,
my girlfriend's a car,
like you were like,
I realize this is,
it even ties in with this jazz night thing because I realized like where she
realized that like half the bad things that happened to her in the last four
years were social media related or more maybe all of them.
I'm thinking about it like if I think of all the bullshit like stress on my life
that I had from fucking social media is real though.
Like I've had a couple of theaters,
cancer chats,
like ruined my life.
I mean strangers like set out,
I'm going to ruin your life.
Like where?
I was like,
wow,
you got a lot of good it.
It costs money now.
It's crazy.
That's when required you get theaters council for I booked to art schools.
I just paid them to rent it like the area and I sold it out myself and then they
would just cancel saying that I do hate speech or something.
What's the saying?
Ah,
there's one merit in Chicago and then Brooklyn School of music.
Just cats on me and I had to switch it that day.
Chicago and Brooklyn though.
Or like hotbeds.
Well Frizzell Chicago was filled with how social and that social shit.
Like I'm a,
I'm a piano player.
I say as Gw,
social jihad is no good.
And I thought that was like my safe spot.
I'm like,
dude,
I'm a piano player in Chicago is so full.
Like dude,
everywhere is,
it's like the nothing from the neverending story.
It's just like everywhere now.
Well,
you know,
dude,
if you go to these underserved markets,
like Detroit's right there,
there's people that want to want to see in Detroit,
Detroit,
mark be fucking amazing
track is that the fucking area was,
and I did this place.
Oh,
small some rock dude.
It was tremendous.
Yeah,
I had a great time in Detroit.
I did that.
Fillmore did two shows there.
It was amazing for sports in there like seven years ago.
I was sick.
Fucking fun man.
They appreciate you.
Well,
it's easy to forget or happy to be there.
You know this horse shit because it's this cult that these people are in that's
in Hollywood and New York and Chicago religious there.
It's not view the rest of the country.
People want,
you know,
this is a thing that you get fooled with social media is you think this is like
reality,
but it is everywhere.
But they don't like it.
That's the difference.
Like,
like Hollywood can have people being like,
oh no,
this is great.
But it is in other,
uh,
colleges and like our college kids write me that they have to sign a white
privileged contract.
It like the college.
I've seen them.
At least they know it means they acknowledged their white privilege,
which is basically,
I don't know,
it's something that happened.
She's what for genocide or whatnot,
but we put you acknowledge your white privilege.
You have it easier.
That's amazing.
I've never heard of it though.
It's unreal.
They're giving kids in certain schools are giving kids lectures on gender and
that how some people are gender fluid,
meaning that they can switch back and forth from male to female and anytime like
it wouldn't wait time.
Do we go,
okay,
maybe that's true,
but what's the odds that that's nonsense?
The I 100% overwhelming.
Kimmy might be someone with some sort of a psychological disorders where they do
bounce back and forth between being a man,
a woman,
but at what point in time could we recognize this is a psychological disorder
and this is just not a natural state of being like having red hair.
By the way.
Also,
I don't give a shit like I know it's nice that involve me.
I need to teach kids at school,
are you going to be your,
they go like,
well,
white is considered default.
I'm like,
well that's because it's a majority white population.
Like default doesn't mean cause I don't understand what people are finding is by
default.
What do you mean?
It doesn't make any sense though.
Like when people go flesh colored bandaids or white,
which I don't even know if that's still true brown bandaids,
but it's,
it's literally a matter a matter of like populate,
like why are you fighting to be default or like the boring,
like I became a comedian to be marginal.
Like on the margins.
I didn't want to be in the main dude.
My hydration margin I get going if I can't go on a fucking horror coaster with
the answer.
The bandaid thing,
it's very easy.
At the time that bandaids were invented,
it was a far greater population of white people.
Yeah,
no shit.
There's more now that's like,
would they say within 30 years white people are going to be the minority.
I think we're also looking forward to it.
Yeah.
Well she is my kid white.
I don't even know.
Your kid is definitely not white and your kids half Mexican.
Yes,
we can.
I spoke this in here by the way.
Yeah,
sure.
I'd rather you not marijuana.
Yeah.
What do you got going on there?
Some little glass pipe.
Yeah.
It's a chillum chillum that's what these fish concert pipe I've shown him was
that thing they do with Hash.
Ah,
sure.
But that's what it,
I mean,
yeah,
it's just the same thing.
So just a a one hitter.
We got joints here.
If you want to spark a joint,
but do want to start,
we can join it.
I think it's cause it's student jet that all this shit's happening because of
what?
Student debt?
No,
is where a lot of fucking,
no one's going to get a job from underwater vagina ballet.
The economy tanked.
All of a sudden there's money to be made and there's 60 grand in debt for
underwater vagina ballet and then they have to like justify it somehow.
It's crazy.
First of all,
if you are an expert,
underwater vagina ballet,
that's a marketable skill team.
Yeah.
Okay.